all right Hank cold-open this week
because we have a couple of important
announcements first off Hank you and I
are going on tour to celebrate the
release of my new book turtles all the
way down which comes out October 10th
and we're gonna be in lots of cities
some of the shows are already sold out
but some are not so if you live in
Washington DC yeah Charlotte North
Carolina Asheville North Carolina
Nashville Tennessee
Indianapolis st. Louis Missouri st. Paul
Minnesota Missoula Montana very excited
from Missoula show Hank we've never
played Missoula before now no in fact I
haven't played Missoula since since the
very first show I ever played which was
a punishment on vlogbrothers we're also
gonna be in Spokane Washington Portland
Oregon San Francisco Pleasanton
California in Los Angeles California the
we're also in Orlando which you skipped
because we haven't figured out how to
actually sell those tickets yet yeah
there's a problem because there is this
big hurricane in Orlando but we are
going to be in Orlando as well hopefully
tickets will be on sale by the time this
podcast goes live we're gonna be in all
those places and you can learn more at
turtles all the way down book.com and
that's also where you can get tickets
we'd love to see you in person
to celebrate Turtles all the way down
and Hank also has an announcement yeah
the second announcement is that we're
changing the way the phrase of the week
works which I I like the suggestion from
rosianna for a more coherent strategy
for phrase of the week which is that
John and I both have separate phrases of
the week the two different phrases and
John knows his and I know mine but we
don't know each other's and at the end
of the episode we're gonna try and guess
which thing the other person said was
the phrase of the week so you have to
get it in and that means maybe wedging
it in at the end but also maybe I'm just
gonna say a bunch of weird stuff and I'm
gonna have no idea
right so we're gonna see if this works
better as a bit thanks to all the
listeners for their helpful game
suggestions for making the phrase of the
week better we really appreciate your
guys's continuing support even when we
have dumb bits you thank you so much
yeah your support and also just
condescending suggestion we're trying to
create like some kind of genius game now
where your constructive criticism means
a lot to us and also your unconstructive
criticism is also very helpful welcome
to dear Hank and John there is that
first pic of a Dear John and Hank it's a
comedy podcast with two brothers we
answer you questions give you to be a
spice to fit you all the week's booster
both of ours and a sealable to behave
John how do I do it I'm great uh my book
comes out in like three weeks and I am a
bit running around like a chicken with
my head cut off but I suspect that I
shouldn't complain to you because you
are experiencing the extreme jet lag of
coming back from Australia last night I
was at dinner mom and dad came over for
dinner and and we had some delicious
food and I was falling asleep at the
dinner table and so they were like well
let's let this poor child to go to sleep
cuz they're my parents and they still
think I'm a child and but I had to edit
some video so I went out to my office to
finish editing my video and then we're
recording this on a Friday and then I
didn't fall asleep until two o'clock in
the morning yeah that was fun I feel
like that first off I know you were
awake after 2 o'clock in the morning
because I received two emails from you
at 3:18 but secondly oh it was it was it
was 5:18 Eastern Time maybe you
shouldn't have been emailing when you
were trying to sleep but yeah well I
what else was I gonna do
I have work to do John I'm either gonna
be using my time wisely but like in the
sleep thing or I'm gonna be using my
time wisely in the getting alright well
the point being we're not gonna be
getting the best Hank this week that's
everybody just needs to reconcile
themselves to that reality this is gonna
be some substandard Hank he's gonna do
his best but we're not gonna get peak
Hank right now I've got a short poem for
you today it's by Langston Hughes it was
actually sent in by listener Shelby
Thank You Shelby for sending in a short
poem and saving me the trouble of having
to find one because I've pretty much run
out of the ones that I know and like
this is a very good short poem though
and it's sort of about death it's called
final curve by
and Hughes when you turn the corner and
you run into yourself then you know you
have turned all the corners that are
left I like it I like it nice and
shortened and it's about turning corners
speaking of turning corners Hank can I
read a science question to you that I
already looked up the answer to see you
don't have to do any any guesswork all
right
I hit me enthusiasm is infectious this
question comes from Conner who writes
Dear John and Hank if the earth and
everything on it was scaled up to the
size of the Sun what size would humans
be too lazy to do the math Conner well
we'd be like puddles little puddles of
goo just that is correct that is correct
we would be tiny puddles of goo or maybe
large puddle is a big but the puddles of
goo yeah big the one thing we would not
be is standing upright sure for
everything on earth would look like you
know those those those fish that lie on
the floor of the ocean and they have
both both their eyes on the same side of
their head because they only have like
one side of their head everything would
look like that a flounder I think is the
one we would all be flounders sent the
earth would be full of huge sentient
flounders just slide it along yeah it'd
be interesting to me what to figure out
what the actual properties of a planet
that size would be with the composition
of earth because of course if a planet
were that size and it were made of
hydrogen it would just be the Sun again
but we're not we don't have that much
hydrogen on earth or that much helium so
fusion would probably not be able to
start up so the question but it probably
still would be like a molten ball
there'd be so much pressure that the
heat from the inside would reach the
outside so in addition to being piles of
goo we would be quickly vaporized piles
of goo is my guess though I can't I
can't be sure so just to clarify this is
because of gravity because gravity on a
much larger earth would exert much more
force pulling
humans down in making them puddles of
goo yeah also even if we were just like
however much bigger the the Sun is than
the earth like even if suddenly we were
all you know a million times bigger or
whatever I think like I think it's about
a million times that's my that's my I
didn't look this up guess if we were a
million times bigger we would still just
be piles of goog because our our bones
would not be able to hold us up and we
would break them and then would just be
flesh bags on like sort of slopping
around on the on the planet that's just
a beautiful image flesh bag slopping
around on the planet it it's one of
those things it just brings a tear to
your eye
alright while researching this question
Hank I ended up following down a rabbit
hole of the question somewhat related
are humans closer in size to the earth
or to an atom of hydrogen mmm I would
say to the earth would be my my gas that
is correct by almost every way of
calculating it if you calculate it
logarithmic Li by mass we're about in
the middle actually but but most most
ways of calculating it if you calculate
it by absolute mass or if you calculate
it by volume etc humans are much closer
in size to the earth than they are to a
hydrogen atom which you know if you're
ever feeling irrelevant just think like
about how irrelevant hydrogen atoms must
feel feeling this question comes from
obviously honestly I might I might have
to fire you and go get a guest toast
right now I think I did great feeling
this question comes from Cheyenne dear
Hank and John I love an Arkansas which
sadly means I have to travel extreme
distances to see my favorite people like
you guys also a high school English
teacher right so my English teachers so
my schedules a little difficult to work
around and their substitute teachers so
my question is how crazy would it be for
me to fly to Georgia for 24 hours to
meet you guys
not from Wyoming Cheyenne well Cheyenne
I've got good news and bad news the good
news is that I've I'm gonna save you the
cost of a plane ticket the bad news is
that the show in Atlanta is sold out oh
man I didn't think about that before I
asked the question what if I wasn't
gonna ask it because it just is just
rubbing salt into a wound it's just
saying okay in addition to this not
being a great idea also you can't do it
however Cheyenne I do have some really
good news for you which is that I am
currently looking at a map of Arkansas
and I think any of us would be shocked
to find two we're in the geographic
location of Arkansas I certainly was yes
I'm looking at it right now on my map
that includes the picture of David
Jeffers hey David Jeffers at the
godswood that's a joke for very select
few people and I find that it's really
really quite not where I thought it was
who is David Jeffers David Jeffers is a
man who is shared his location with me
on Google Maps it's the only one who's
ever I don't know why but he he knows my
email address cuz because my email
address is public and he shared so I
always know exactly where David Jeffries
is he's usually in Charlotte North
Carolina I hope that he comes to our
North Carolina shell so that you don't
you know about David Jeffries Red John
know he is sad III want once upon a time
I was doing a live stream and I was I
had my might I was screen sharing and I
was looking on my map and there's David
Jeffries sure enough that I got really
confused and I found him on Twitter and
he was like yeah I shared my location
with you and I was like well no he was
like nobody else has done that and it's
like no it's just you just not like none
of my actual friends know other
strangers just just the in that map of
the United States of America and David
Jeffers okay all right I did not know
about David Jeffers I've never even
heard that name before I have no idea
what's happening right
I feel like I am on a train that is off
the rails that is like and at any moment
I am going to fly off of a bridge and
fall into the ocean but the point is
that Arkansas turns out to be right next
to Tennessee and Tennessee turns out to
contain one of our shows which is in
Nashville so instead of going to the
sold-out show in Atlanta that is further
away from the not yet sold out show in
Nashville why don't you just go to
Nashville and yes obviously you should
take time away from educating America's
students to visit Hank and I in
Nashville of course that goes without
saying
no you shouldn't I don't know do
whatever feels right I'm gonna feel
weird Hank if somebody spends like plane
ticket money to come and see us because
the show it's hopefully it's gonna be
like better than this pod but it's not
gonna be that much better yeah well it's
not really a plane ticket even where
like if you go from Arkansas to now well
we don't know we don't know we're in
Arkansas this person I assume that they
live in Hot Springs Arkansas because
that's the best town name so I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna find out how long
it takes to get from Hot Springs
Arkansas to Nashville Tennessee based on
my understanding of Google Maps it takes
like three inches it takes well so I
just typed in Arkansas to Nashville and
and Google Maps has chosen just a
completely arbitrary spot not in the
middle of Arkansas to be where the it
starts and it's a five-hour drive but it
is a completely arbitrary spot not in
the middle of Arkansas right but I'm
pretty sure that this person lives in
Hot Springs because that is a funny
place name and so from Hot Springs to
Nashville is six hours so I mean maybe a
six hour drive is on the cusp of
acceptability here's I don't want to I
don't want to oversell the show I want
to be very clear about this Cheyenne
like there's gonna be a live dear Hank
and John segment it's gonna be maybe
four to five percent better than the
kind of cell optimal podcasting that
you're used to there's gonna be some
other segments that are gonna be fun and
I think it'll be a great time but I
don't know if I don't
if I would spend six hours alone in a
car I would I would but but I like Hank
a lot I loved seeing Hank perform so I
don't know it's up to you do what is
best for you John I have an update okay
regarding Arkansas so okay the arbitrary
point not in the middle of Arkansas that
Google Maps has chosen uh-huh it's in
it's in it's in the middle of a field it
appears to not be a farm or anything
it's just a field like a and next next
to the arbitrary spot that Google Maps
has chosen to represent them at the
Arkansas is just just a thing and it
says women's clothing store but not it's
not on anything it's just on the field
this field and it says women's clothing
store has one star in one review John it
has a review it has a review amis about
to Ray Lewis it says it's from Lucy a
local guide who has 18 reviews in a
month ago she left this review John one
star fake Lucy Lucy local guide pourcel
drives to the definition of Arkansas
according to google which is in the
middle of a field I agree with you I'm
looking at it now it is in the exact
middle of a field that does not appear
to be cultivated in any way there is no
road there does not appear to me this
place does not appear to be accessible I
think it's a cow pasture I think I see
some feed troughs but yeah I yeah it
appears to get maybe pigs it is some
kind of animal field and there is a sign
that says women's clothing store and
there's just a review that just says
fake and the pourcel hiking out you know
into the middle of this cow pasture it
must be at least a half mile walk from
the nearest road the nearest road by the
way is called peanut Ridge Road so you
walk half a mile from peanut Ridge Road
to women's clothing store in the middle
of Arkansas as defined by Google Maps
only to learn that shock of shocks it is
fake goodness well there's no save so
many people so many
trips to a fake women's clothing store
like just what I was saying that this
podcast wasn't that good and you weren't
at your best you just literally took
everything to a new and beautiful level
oh well it was a risky move John I feel
like I made a risky move what it paid
off all right you got a question for us
I don't that's the final question that's
it we're done
why even continue all right Hank I can't
believe we didn't answer this question
first because it is time-sensitive it
comes from Kelsey who writes Dear John
and Hank help I am 26 minutes away from
meeting my blind date for this evening
what do I say upon seeing him we've
texted for a little bit but I've never
met this person face-to-face do I say
hello Ricky I'm Kelsey but you already
knew that do I make a comment about the
fact that we share a birthday do I give
him a hug I need to walk the delicate
line between being cool and still
demonstrating an appropriate amount of
excitement help me help me help me big
fan of the pod Kelsey
all right first off this email was sent
to us six weeks ago so we want an update
how'd it go
based on Kelsey's apparent level of
enthusiasm about this blind date I
suspect that they are now married yeah I
mean what's what's Ricky got that is I'd
like to see I'd like to see Ricky's
tinder profile because apparently it's
amazing yeah just say whatever whatever
impressed you so much about Ricky say
that hello Ricky your cheekbones astound
me the the cat in the background of your
picture on tinder that is a top-notch
cat I can tell that you are a cat lover
you're oh man not your pot and pan set I
can tell you're an amazing chef the fact
that you have a basil plant there with
your stuff like aa top knot you are
something else my friend Ricky I heart
you
it's what oh don't say that don't say
that I so I've been in this situation a
couple times in my life most notably
when I met my first major girlfriend who
I'd known on the internet for a long
time but because it was a different era
we'd never exchanged pictures so she
just told me I'm going to be the person
in the parking lot who looks like a
cartoon character because my eyes are
too big
so I was just like scanning scanning
scanning and then I did see a person
with very big eyes and I was like Marie
and she was like John and that's how it
started so I think that the first thing
that you should actually say is Ricky
yeah yeah you got a pretty much
Ricky question mark because you could
not you're not positive although you
probably are because you've seen his
tinder profile with all the all the
such-and-such I don't know how it works
John I haven't been on a date basically
ever I went on a date on Wednesday with
Sarah we had a great time actually you
know what we did we had like we had a
wonderful date night we had a cocktail
and then we went out to dinner and then
it was only like eight 20 because I'm
old like I like looked at our phones at
the end of dinner and we were like the
kids aren't even asleep yet so so I was
like what do you want to do and she was
like I don't know what do you want to do
and I was like we could go to Target and
she was like yes so we went to Target
and there's something it's funny because
when you go to Target on a date it's a
completely different experience than
going to Target
just because you got to like pick up
diapers or whatever so we went to Target
on a date and it was so fun and we
bought all kinds of crazy crap we bought
we bought this new Trivial Pursuit game
that was super fun and we went home and
played it was just like going to target
first I know this isn't your question
Kelsey but you need to take Rikki to
target because if you guys can have a
great experience at Target it is true
love yeah man that's not a bad idea
nobody goes shopping on first dates I
feel like you'll learn a great deal
about each other so sarah has a thing
that we did that I thought was so sweet
and cute and then eventually she
confessed that she'd like previously
done this date with every single boy
she'd ever dated all right but it is
super cute this is the date you go to
the dollar store and you pick out one
item for each other so like you can only
spend a dollar but you can buy the
person anything
great that's very that's a great and fun
cute date but it is weird to think about
Sarah doing that over and over and over
I wouldn't say over and over and over
again are you Holly good you know
yeah what did she get you do you
remember I don't thank God she doesn't
listen to this podcast I'd be in trouble
okay I think we got it
to Chelsea maybe Kelsey Kelsey I
remembered Rickie in this name but not
yours
Rickie is a good name okay get to the
next question hey this one's from Eric
who asks dear Hank and John are you
supposed to ask a father for his
daughter's hand in marriage I mean like
it's her hand shouldn't I just ask her
she's very forward-thinking so I know
that she won't care but I fear her
father will take offense if I don't
should I do it to respect him even
though I don't think it's necessary help
it's happening October 13th all right
yeah we got it in time we're in in time
just barely yeah so I don't know what
you did Hank I did ask but I asked both
of I asked both of Sarah's parents I
didn't just ask her dad and I also Sarah
knew that I was going to ask her parents
so I'm not sure that that really count
so it was like for me it was a way of
observing the formality and saying to
you know to Sarah's family that they
were important to me and were gonna be
an important part of our marriage and
and that my relationship with them and
our relationship with them was important
while still not making the proposal
contingent upon anyone other than you
know the two of us really at its core
yeah that is also what I did I think
that this only becomes a sort of weird
question when they might say no but yeah
I was not right you Asian I did have a
pretty good idea going in that there was
going to be a yes although I was still
extremely nervous and I have to say I
mean I think I've told the story before
of when I actually when this actually
went down but
like a month before that I was with
Sarah's dad who's a wonderful warm
incredibly kind person and has become a
you know great friend to me but at the
time I found him extremely intimidating
just you know like just intimidating
he's so smart and just as really and I
remember like being in his office and he
was holding this like crystal elephant
paperweight thing and he was like
holding it and like moving it from one
hand to the other and I was like is he
gonna throw it at me I was trying to
like bring up in some way the sort of
like issue of whether this was going to
be a sort of permanent arrangement
between Sarah and me and I was just like
you know what we're gonna have to abort
this mission is gonna abort before back
away
just be like great talk it's better to
survive yeah that did win yeah I
remember I mean I called Mike in my now
in-laws on the phone and I was like can
I get both you on the line so it's not
like they were confused about what was
happening like it's not like I called
them a bunch right right yeah but yeah I
think it's I think it's and it is
clearly based on you know the the way
that society is structured which we
don't always have to love we don't we
don't do not love the effects of all of
that but I don't know that this is
really upholding the patriarchy it's
just sort of like that I think it's more
cute oh well I mean it depends on how
it's done like anything right no and it
depends on what the what the stakes are
and all of that and we don't know the
particulars of this but obviously I
think that whether or not to get married
should be a conversation between the two
people getting married yes I agree and I
feel like it should yeah where it starts
a conversation not like that's my
problem with proposals is that too often
they are not preceded by
long in-depth careful thoughtful
conversations and and there is something
weird about the like I asked you accept
or reject thing rather than it beings
you know a place that gets arrived at
together so in our case like there was a
proposal but there was also an awareness
for many months before the proposal that
we were going to get married yeah
indeed all right I got another question
for you okay why are you laughing cuz
I'm so terrible at podcasting no you're
great at it that Arkansas bit was so
good hey Hank
why don't you go look up what Google of
apps says other states where other
states are located and maybe see if you
can find another fake women's clothing
store meanwhile this question comes from
Katherine who writes Dear John and Hank
help I just got tickets to the book tour
and this will be my first time seeing
John in person Hank isn't coming to my
stop oh right I should mention that yeah
not be at the stops in Atlanta and
Asheville instead there will be amazing
guests Hanks Hank I don't know if I
should announce who the guest Hanks are
because I don't want to like raise
people's expectation that they're gonna
be celebrities but because they aren't
but in my opinion they will be better
than celebrities also I don't know if
you know who they are I John and the
geographical or Google Maps chosen
center of Illinois which is as you might
expect cornfield uh-huh
there are I don't know 30 GMT global
money transfer locations oh so this is a
pattern see it would appear it would
appear that this is not a kind of one
time wait John there's also a was Azara
but the address of this ara is Al Araf
Manila Avenue 8 Jerusalem nine four one
four nine zero for Israel okay well
something is going wrong well Hank I
don't want to I don't want to veer too
far away from the question of who the
gas tanks are in Asheville and Atlanta
however
um in the geographical location chosen
by Google to represent Texas which is
just off of a road called frost lane I
would say about an hour and a half south
of Abilene there is a hotel named Magoo
glue it's the Google it as two point
three stars
and three reviews one five-star review
in the last week from Bella who writes
that is wonderful and then two one-star
reviews with no with no particular text
associated with them but perhaps
somebody you know made it to this
completely empty field in the middle of
Texas off of frost Lane and discovered
that there is not in fact a hotel named
boo Google
oh my well okay so we've we've
discovered some kind of bug with Google
Maps John but if you were or have me if
you would like to transfer some money
the the the center of Illinois is a
great place to do it it's just
cornfields and money transfer centers so
interestingly the definition of Indiana
my home state according to Google if you
just type in Indiana
it actually takes you relatively close
oh wait no that's my that's my house oh
I see it takes okay I see it knows where
I am okay I'm not sharing my location
with you but apparently I am sharing it
with Google so there's gonna be guests
Hanks in theirs Asheville and Atlanta
stops it's still going to be a very fun
show but there there will be no Hank
point being what should you wear was the
question I believe I don't even know oh
right yeah the question is what do
people usually wear do most people wear
like John green or nerdfighter related
shirts or nerdy shirts in general your
advice as much appreciated turtles and
tours Katherine yes most people I I
wouldn't say most people but a lot of
people wear like whatever fandom you
want to brag about whether that's the
Harry Potter fandom or some a book you
love or if you want to wear a pizza John
shirt you'll certainly never feel more
comfortable in a Pizza John shirt then
have a tour event but anything that
makes you feel comfortable and happy and
relaxed and not not overwhelmed I
wouldn't wear necessarily like formal
wear although I will likely be wearing a
suit at least for part of the evening
you should not feel obligated to I'm not
going to be wearing a suit though I may
be wearing a kind of suit it depends on
how you I don't know I got that email at
3:18 in the morning when you sent it and
I was just like what is like what is
happening to Hank this evening I can't I
can't reveal exactly what he purchased
but he was like I just purchased X suit
and I'd like to wear it at every tour
event stop but it will necessitate a
quick costume change I was just like why
is Hank thinking this at 3:18 in the
morning now what exactly I had a bunch
of other really good ideas about the for
the tour were laying in bed and I I did
not and then once upon awaking in the
morning realized that they were they
were low quality ideas yeah that is so
IV that is such a problem for me like if
the ideas that I'd dream about were as
good as the actual idea I would be a
genius all right John this next question
comes from Vanessa who a steering can
I'm getting married soon and it's time
to start addressing those wedding
invites since you've both married men
and have been involved with the details
of weddings should the addresses on the
wedding invite envelopes be handwritten
or as printing addresses on envelopes
acceptable I realize that most these
envelopes are just gonna end up in
hopefully the recycling bin but this
debate is caused quite a stir in my
family my mother insists that the 100
plus invitations be handwritten wild my
sister and peers think that I'm just
gonna paraphrase here is silly John well
Vanessa concludes calligraphy pens and
carpal tunnel Vanessa yeah I mean it's
so why they make it this whole process
is
already a lot of work you do not need to
make it more work do I don't need to
make it more work all right we're gonna
disagree about this okay in the same way
that like you know when you get the
wedding when you get wedding presents if
you're lucky enough to get wedding
presents when you write the thank you
note I think that even though I hate
writing from my hand and and it causes
my arm to cramp and I just the whole
time I'm thinking about how much faster
this would be if I could type it and
just email this thank-you letter I do
think that there is value to the act and
I know that this makes me a conservative
old fuddy-duddy but I do think that
there is something to the handwritten
note I do think that there's something I
understand is mama's ition now here's
press here's the thing here's the thing
I agree I wouldn't press it is what what
if you pay someone to write it down is
that it's still like I know a lot of
people who have done that who've gotten
calligraphers to like write the
calligraphy all right the address and to
me that's like that's like more work and
you didn't do it yourself so how is that
better than getting a printer to do it
well it is very beautiful though it is
nice it's lovely
I completely agree that it's lovely but
it but but is it about the aesthetic
experience or is it about putting in
like making this something that you did
to show that you care about the people
right i i 100% understand at some point
if you're if you're outsourcing the
personal touch is it a personal touch
yeah this is something like that's what
I thought about that a lot when people
would say about the signing thing with
signing all the copies of turtles all
the way down if people when people would
say like why don't you just get a stamp
or an autopen or whatever and it's like
there's something about the physical
doing of it but at the same time if you
do something 200 thousand times it's
obviously not that hard you know like
the thought that if not that personal
in there that I understand everything
that I have done 200,000 times was
pretty easy I would submit that you
haven't done one of the things that I
liked a lot about the signing is that I
don't think you have done a lot of
things 200,000 times no it's a pretty
it's a pretty small number of things
like I've I've taken more than 200,000
breaths my heart has beaten more than
200,000 times right but that wasn't a
choice yeah but yeah you're right
there's very very little I mean like I
probably afflict my toes back and forth
200,000 times because I do it all the
time and that's kind of a choice it's
like it's but it's definitely got back
back their motor memory that's not
something I'm thinking about how many
have I eaten 200,000 some things is
there something I've eaten 200,000 of
like probably even 200,000 beans for
sure definitely definitely 200,000
grains of rice well yeah but I don't
yeah that's true 600,000 grains of rice
but I like I like sort of exploring as
you know Hank exploring extreme
repetition I've liked it since I was a
kid it's always been it's always been a
source of joy for me today's podcast in
fact is brought to you by doing
something 200,000 times rarer than you
might think
rather than you might think and also a
great way to develop a skill like
drawing a fish this podcast is
additionally brought to you by
substandard Hank substandard Hank
available right now through the magic of
Australia and today's podcast is brought
to you by women's clothing store women's
clothing store Arkansas
[Laughter]
and finally this book and finally this
podcast is brought to you by John's
father-in-law's crystal elephant murder
weapon or just PayPal a good one that's
a good one okay we also have a real
sponsor for today's video the sponsor is
fracture I'm actually Hank I'm gonna put
a
picture of one of the fracture things
that we got here in our office it's
actually Rosie Ana's not mine but it's
really it shows what a cool thing it is
so you can go over to the patreon a
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John and
see that but you can go to fracture me
comm slash podcast right now and when
you do the one question survey you can
enter to your Hank and John is as how
you found out about fracture there's a
really cool way of taking the pictures
that you have that are on the internet
or on your Instagram or on your phone
and turning them into like physical
objects that exist in real space and
that you can hang on your wall
they're very nice I just got mine when I
got back from Australia they were
waiting for me which is a nice school to
present and I've got a really cute one
of four and but the one that I got
that's really quite large for the office
is a high-res of the Curiosity rover
which is do it looks so good I mean my
meat let's be honest NASA did most of
the work there but fractures
contribution was also good yeah it's
just it's a cool it's a cool easy gift
but also a cool easy thing to have for
yourself and you can get 10% off of your
first order if you go to fracture me.com
slash podcast and please mention again
dear Hank and John in there one question
survey one more time that URL is
fracture me.com slash podcast check it
out it is really cool alright one last
problem before we get to I don't know
how how's that podcast work John Hank
that's that was good one last problem we
do tend to answer problems not questions
alright Hank this question comes from
Aaron who writes to your child Hank I
have a mom and I am a mom while I love
my mother dearly how do I get her to
call me less frequently she called
several times a day until I pick up the
phone and the conversations last for
hours I'm busy at home with three kids
including a set of twins and the time I
do have alone is better spent regaining
my sanity than listening to my mom
rehash her last meal and the effect of
it on her bowels I Baga she also says
that she's literally developed cubital
tunnel syndrome from the repetitive
elbow strain of talking
the phone well I have a solution for
that which is to get a Bluetooth headset
but that is not going that is not going
to resolve the the larger issues yeah of
establishing boundaries and getting your
mom to acknowledge them Aaron goes on to
say that she's tried that repeatedly and
that her mom gets hurt and then also
just doesn't acknowledge the boundaries
it's one thing if you hurt somebody's
feelings and then slowly they understand
the boundaries it's another thing if you
hurt someone's feelings and then they
don't um respect the boundaries anyway
then it's just frustrating oh man I have
no solution but this sounds terrible
that's my this sounds very hard
I mostly can also only commiserate in
this situation because it's not
fortunately not something I have a ton
of experience with I guess that I would
say that it probably makes sense not to
reach out although I appreciate your
reaching out to us but to reach out to a
therapist and maybe potentially even a
therapist who you can talk with your mom
to since you're talking with your mom
hours a day anyway maybe one hour a week
with a therapist might help better
acknowledge the boundaries and better
establish them and keep everybody kind
of playing by the rules but I would
recommend I would really recommend
talking to someone in this situation a
professional because I do think that
that would be tremendously exhausting
especially when you have three kids
including a set of twins
Hank is there anything in the world
scarier than the words twins
I guess triplets triplets is scarier
tuplets is a scary word Aaron has a
follow-up question here but before I get
to that I will say I don't know if this
is a very practical suggestion which is
to text your mom and say I can't talk
today and do that and do that every
other day so at least you're not doing
it talking to her every day Monday
Wednesday Friday just a standard 8 a.m.
can't talk today I don't I don't think
that's going to work
doesn't seem like that's that the root
of the problem is a lack of of getting
texts saying that we can't talk today
but Aaron's follow-up question is do you
guys have any advice on how I can get my
three and a half year old to figure out
the difference between pants and a shirt
I mean dude that sounds gross
no yeah exactly hold on to that as long
as you can
that's like cute when Alice was little
instead of saying yes she said I or I
and everyone like the preschool like
yeah exactly like a pirate and everyone
at like the teachers at the preschool
would be like have you noticed that
Alice doesn't say yes she always says I
and I was like yeah I've noticed it it's
amazing and they were like well we've
been working with her on the word yeah
I'm like stop do not work with her on
the word yes once she starts saying yes
she's never gonna say I ever again and
it's amazing I have to say that since
then Alice has started to say yes but
she has also developed an incredibly
cute new enthusiastic yes like when
she's really psyched about saying yes to
something when it's like Alice would you
like some ice cream instead of saying I
or yes she says
yuppers oh my god it's so cute it makes
me melt John okay we got some some good
sign-off sent in but before I get to
those I want to note that you John was
adding adding notes to the podcast
document in the header area and so the
top of every one of our pages of the
podcast doc just says in all caps
Arkansas no regrets
hashtag no regrets all right so we've
got some of these names specific sign
offs you might remember that we asked
our listeners if they had any names
specific sign offs for us and Amy a nope
nope wrong person's name sorry Amy I'm
sure you're great too but that is not
the person that I wanted to read the
thing from it was Miranda Miranda sent
in one her husband is named John and he
signs off
his emails jonvoyage which is pretty
great that's a pretty good one I'm gonna
go through a few ali-a has neither Dilli
Nord Ali Ali Lane says life in the fast
lane page on to the next page from Molly
poppin Molly I don't know we make drug
jokes on this channel but it's not
Molly's fault that she that they ended
up naming a street drug after her or
maybe it is we actually don't know much
about Molly because we also got seven
hundred fifty seven thousand in
Corrections and I want to thank each and
every one of you for writing in to point
out that flamey-o hotman was not as we
assumed a Latin sign-off but rather a
reference to Avatar The Last Airbender
I'm not not sure how like what mine
state we were in to think that flamey-o
hotman was latin i just i mean i watched
the clip of flamey-o hotman happening on
Avatar The Last Airbender and I gotta
say it did did not make any sense it did
I if you don't know avatar the last the
last airbender it does not make a ton of
sense but also so Hank because I did not
remember saying flamey-o hotman or
whatever that I said people kept sending
me that for one particular clip from
YouTube and and I was like I don't
understand is this a meme that I'm like
too old to get and so for the longest
thought so finally I went to rosy on and
I was like this is such a tear this is
such a forty year old person thing but
can you please explain this meme to me
and she was like that's not a meme you
idiot this it's a reference to your
podcast we also got a correction from
Phineas who wrote in to say that when
Hank called the lead singer of the band
Phish Trey Parker he was incorrect the
lead singer of the band Phish is Trey
Anastasio and Trey Parker co-created the
television program South Park
they have literally nothing else in
common well I mean there aren't that
many trays so yeah I guess I guess that
might just be made about that also
Adi wrote in to say how dare you been
got lots of presents and the night was
entirely focused on him angrily Adi
along with a picture from Ben's birthday
this is a reference to something that
happened in the podcast that I don't
remember
Amy writes in with it with a bit of a
response to say I work at a pregnancy
clinic and in response to April's
question about what to tell parents when
they see their baby and are concerned I
wanted to share that line that has
worked for me when I see a moment of
concern pass over their face I say he
gets even cuter which implies that the
baby is already cute but also not to
worry he's not always going to look that
way all right Hank now we have to guess
each other's phrases of the week are you
ready to guess my phrase of the week I
am John what was it I think your phrase
of the week was crystal elephant it was
crystal elephant paperweight oh well Wow
I mean I had to make a muscle
I made up a whole story about my
father-in-law and a desperate attempt to
fit crystal elephant paperweight
somewhere like it's very difficult but
yes I lost I think that yours was pot
and pan set no it was basil plant you
were close in the right area but I got
the wrong detail
[Laughter]
all right well Hank wins the first round
one and possibly only of the phrase of
the week game no that was so much fun
nervous the whole time I was freaking
out a hundred percent of the pod and
while I was saying basil plant my heart
rate was like 120 beats per minute I was
like I'm doing it here I go I'm going to
my basil plant and I'm just gonna rush
right past it and then and I was
stammering I was so excited the news
from AFC Wimbledon is as follows on
September 9th AFC Wimbledon lost to nil
to Portsmouth in what was by all
accounts not of
very good performance and then on
September 12th AFC Wimbledon drew 1-1
with Gillingham the gills the gillies
the givers drew 1-1 but it was a
purportedly I did not see it purportedly
a better game at least according to
Twitter AFC Wimbledon seemed more likely
to score second goal and were very
unfortunate to give up the equalizer
it's a very frustrating result though
because Gillingham played an entire half
of football with only 10 players and
because they had a red card and so it
was frustrating this means that
Wimbledon now ha it's tied seven games
into what will be a 46 game season so a
too early to panic but only won one spot
away from the relegation zone five
points from seven games which is not
enough not not enough period hard stop
that that is the situation John this
week in Mars news
September 15th saw the end of the 20th
annual international Mars Society
convention I don't know if you know but
I was at the very first annual Mars
Society convention that makes me feel
old I've been into Mars for 20 years
John more than the number of things
happened George Whitesides a Virgin
Galactic gave a keynote address or a
presentation where he discussed Virgin
Galactic's move into powered spaceflight
where they're starting to do good good
stuff following their accident on in
2014
the keynote address was by Anusha I'm
sorry and they even had a panel of
science fiction authors including one of
my one of my favs Larry Niven so so so
much good things happened at the Mars
Society convention that I didn't go to
or participate in but it looks like a
good nerdy time just just some serious
nerding out John all right there we go
that noted we're now going to record our
special podcast over at patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John called this
week in Ryan's wherever
week we discussed for five or ten
minutes Orion whose name is at this
point almost never Ryan but thank you to
everybody for listening Hank thank you
for potting with me
what did we learn
John we learned that one of your first
dates with Sarah was at the dollar store
and one of your last ones was at Target
that's right we're moving up in the
world we learned that there is a lot of
things in the middle of what Google
defines as the United States we did we
did we learned that the middle of
Illinois has has a lot going on we also
learned that shirts and pants are the
same they're essentially essentially
interchangeable and lastly we've learned
that even a suboptimal hank is still an
excellent tank oh thank you very much
John that's nice to hear this podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
sheridan Gibson it's edited by Nicholas
Jenkins or the head of community and in
something else is Victoria Bonjour now
communication communication okay the
music that you hear is by them the
wonderful legendary fantastic optimal
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome you
can email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com great ending this is so
sub-optimal
[Music]
you